o que a bianca tá chovendo aonde nós
vamos ensaiar
tu vai para o segundo andar se a bianca
é sério isso é uma casa velha aonde nós
vamos ensaiar vai para biblioteca uma
coisa que eu sempre treinei na minha
vida desde menina pobre e sem recursos
era sonhar e escrever histórias o mundo
da leitura é perfeito e nele cabe tudo
assim como o mundo é antes dele ficar
preto era uma vez uma menina que
acreditava que podia transformar o mundo
e o que mais ela fazia era escrever
cartinhas para sua família com mensagens
de amor e paz porque o que ela queria
era ajuda para construir um mundo novo
é essa menina sou eu eu sempre fui
apaixonada pela ideia de que tudo aquilo
que a gente pensa e escreve vai
acontecer
e quando eu era criança que eu escrevi
ia que eu ia dar aulas para as crianças
e aos 14 anos a minha mãe juntou várias
historinhas que eu fazia enviou para o
medidora essas historinhas se
transformar em um livro o reino de amor
e foi a partir daí que eu comecei a
escrever o meu primeiro projeto aos 16
anos eu tinha certeza que o que eu
queria era ter uma escola a minha mãe me
apoiou de primeira o meu pai foi contra
no início mas ele foi o primeiro
patrocinador porque a gente abriu as
portas da sala do apartamento que ele
pagava um suor do trabalho dele
balconista desde 14 anos de idade era
difícil para ele acreditar em um mundo
melhor e foi aí que eu comecei
alfabetizar a receber as crianças na
minha casa
oi e a partir desse momento a gente
entendeu que a necessidade de educação
dessas crianças era muito maior do que a
gente imaginava e eu nem preciso contar
para vocês eles tinham fome eles
precisavam de banho de amor e de
cuidados eles não tinham básico e eu
ouvi pessoas do próprio voluntariado que
estavam à minha volta dizerem essas mães
não querem nada elas querem alargar o
filhos com vocês para vocês cuidarem e
eu falei você conhece essa mãe
e você sabe a história dessa família
se você já parou para pensar quantas
vezes essa mãe vai e volta leva um filho
para escola e traz de novo essa mãe
nunca ouviu falar de sonhos essa família
ela nunca ouviu que eles podem ser
melhor que eles podem ser aquilo que
eles quiserem e foi a partir daí que eu
comecei a escrever um novo projeto e
nesse novo projeto toda a família estava
incluída a gente iria receber as
crianças e também as crianças as
famílias dessas crianças e a partir daí
a gente criou uma pedagogia diferenciada
onde não é porque a família que a gente
recebe porque nós não somos
assistencialistas o perfil de famílias
do instituto mundo novo são famílias que
querem escrever uma nova história são
famílias que querem romper com o ciclo
de pobreza e miséria
e traumas e de sofrimento e essas
famílias elas assinam termo de
compromisso para que a partir daquele
momento elas vão vestir a camisa do
projeto acompanhar educação dos filhos e
trazerem essa transformação para dentro
da sua casa e assim a gente começa a
escrever uma nova história
e em 16 anos de trabalho a gente vem
colecionando histórias de sucesso
e a história do vinícius ele entrou na
ong com apenas 6 anos sem saber ler e
escrever com uma série de dificuldades
ele começou a se interessar por ballet e
no ano passado ele passou na maior a
opção de balé do país e hoje aos 11 anos
o vinícius mudou a história de toda a
sua família através do balé uma família
que vivia em extrema pobreza que o sonho
da mãe dele era tem um piso dentro de
casa uma casa sem banheiro uma casa que
faltava tudo que a mãe muita das vezes
deixou de comer para dar para os filhos
a irmã mais nova e o irmão mais velho e
o vinicius hoje eles escrevem uma nova
história em joinville santa catarina
e eles moram lá e o vinicius foi um dos
protagonistas no documentário
internacional do bolshoi onde eles
contaram a história de transformação da
vida dele
e além do vinícius hoje a gente tem
cinco ex-alunos contratados no projeto
uma delas a lorraine que foi minha aluna
eu tive a oportunidade de ser professora
dela e hoje ela é nossa coordenadora
pedagógica tem pós-graduação
oi e me ajuda cria junto comigo essa
pedagogia diferenciada através de ensino
de valores e assim como ela fala que a
bianca lá naquela casa velha eu fui
feliz lá eu aprendi a sonhar eu aprendi
que eu poderia sim fazer uma faculdade
porque foi a primeira do núcleo familiar
inteiro a estar numa faculdade
ah e hoje a lorraine consegue
transformar a vida de outras crianças
também
oi e o mais interessante é que essas
vidas são transformadas alina mundo novo
que era uma casa velha e hoje o que a
gente quer trazer para as crianças é o
melhor as pessoas chegam lá e olham
grama sintética tv de plasma refeitório
brinquedoteca biblioteca teatro sim o
nada eles têm uma fora aqueles vão ter
tudo
e além de amor eles vão ter o que eles
podem e querem ser e eles vão ter o
pertencimento daquilo ali para que eles
possam de fato escrever uma nova
história o leonardo foi mais de um foi
mais um aluno meu e também foi da turma
da lorraine e o menino que morava no
morro negro filho de mãe solteira que
passava por diversas dificuldades por
ter muitos irmãos não tinha gosto pelos
estudos
oi e ele conta o mais interessante que
ele conta é que ele fala na mundo novo
eu aprendi não só estudar mas ali eu
aprendi a valorizar minha família a
cuidar da minha mãe dos meus irmãos e
hoje ele passou para um concurso público
ele é militar da marinha ele está em são
paulo bem de vida bem sucedido seguindo
uma carreira brilhante
ó e além do leo a gente tem diversas
histórias de sucesso que a gente
coleciona e o que mais a gente quer na
vida dessas crianças é transformar a
vida deles através da educação porque a
gente acredita que com educação de
qualidade é possível sim mudar o mundo e
o meu maior orgulho é quando me mandou
mensagem dizendo que a minha filha está
estudando sobre você e ela vai se
fantasiar de bianca na escola
é uma mãe me mandou uma mensagem de
natal dizendo que as crianças do 4º ano
estavam estudando a minha história e a
filha dela ia se vestir de bianca e isso
é é um orgulho é o que a gente vê
entende o quanto o sonho de uma criança
pode se tornar real quando as pessoas
olhavam para mim e diziam era só uma
criança ela não sabe o que ela está
fazendo primeiro pobre não ajuda a pobre
segundo você tão inteligente porque que
você não faz um concurso público
é porque você não arranja um emprego de
verdade
bom e foi ali que eu tinha certeza que o
que eu queria fazer da minha vida para
sempre era transformar vidas através da
educação
o instituto mundo novo ele tá numa
comunidade esquecida que a comunidade da
chatuba em mesquita na baixada
fluminense ea gente vem escrevendo
stories criando pontes de oportunidades
para crianças para famílias inteiras
através de projetos de educação e
cultura e quando falam que é pro parar
de fazer tudo isso porque você estuda
tanto para ficar na chatuba para que
tudo isso você pode ser mais que isso e
eu digo a minha missão é transformar
vidas de crianças que assim como eu não
tiveram oportunidade quando eu era
criança eu não tive um espaço de
convivência além do da escola
e para desenvolver as minhas habilidades
os meus pais pobre com ajuda da minha
família eu consegui construir o mundo
novo
ah e hoje eu possibilita que crianças e
adolescentes e famílias inteiras têm
oportunidades que eu não tive
é porque seu uma jovem dentro de uma
comunidade e querer desfrutar de
oportunidades desfrutar de educação de
qualidade é quase impossível é quase
impossível e eu queria mostrar que era
possível eu queria mostrar que através
daquele trabalho de qualidade aquelas
crianças pudessem ser transformadas hoje
o miguel que entrou com quatro anos no
instituto mundo novo e se formou na
educação infantil porque um dos
problemas que as crianças não estavam na
escola
oi e ele se formou na educação infantil
da ong hoje ele tem 19 anos é bailarino
e acabou de ganhar uma bolsa para
estudar três anos em portugal
e já ganhou as passagens e agora nós
estamos agilizando para que ele possa
realizar mais esse sonho a família do
miguel uma família muito especial para
gente a mãe eu voluntária existe um
rodízio de voluntariado dentro do
instituto e quando a gente recebe essas
famílias essas famílias elas têm uma
série de oficinas numa das oficinas que
foi de contação de histórias uma mãe
chegou e disse nossa eu nunca ouvi uma
história nunca ninguém contou uma
história para mim e ali elas podem ter
esse mundo esse mundo mágico esse mundo
colorido nesse mundo onde elas podem ser
aquilo que elas quiserem ser e o que a
gente quer com isso tudo a mostrar que
dividir é melhor forma de ser feliz quem
nunca ajudou está perdendo o melhor da
vida
é o amor ele é capaz de curar de
transformar e não precisa de muito basta
querer acreditar inscrever e sonhar que
vai realizar
e aí